voilà voilà un amendement
particulièrement important puisque nous
sommes attachés aux carrières de maire
de famille et faire en sorte
effectivement que cette carrière soit
reconnue avant de présenter le moment je
voudrais remercier Bruno Retailleau ça
fait
ça fait nombre d'années qu'il est très
sensible ce problème des maires de
famille à leur carrière hachée des
difficultés qu'on peut rencontrer quand
on élève ses enfants et qu'on continue à
travailler et il m'a confié une mission
de réflexion
que nous avons largement débattu à la
commission des affaires sociales et qui
est tout à fait essentiel parce que
c'est un marqueur un marqueur fort de
notre attanchement attachement à ces
mères de famille
nous avons dans la proposition je vais
vous faire travailler pour toujours
garder les principes
et ça mérite quelques instants si vous
permettez
principe que
constatons tous les pensions des mers de
famille sont moins élevés que celle des
hommes au niveau des pensions de
retraite Compte tenu de difficultés de
carrière qu'elles peuvent rencontrer
de même nous pensons que le dispositif
actuel de majoration
majoration différenciée
selon la maternité l'éducation des
enfants l'adoption la répartition
éventuellement de ces majorations de
trimestres différentes
quand vous êtes fonctionnaire où vous
avez pas le nombre de trimestres 4
trimestres avant 2004 deux trimestres
après 2004 de majoration et nous lui
comptions prendre en compte
effectivement cette différence
et puis il y a la durée effectivement et
là aussi toujours la même logique quand
on donne à un âge anticipé de départ
parce que nous avons travaillé sur
toutes ces solutions là quand on donne
un agent anticipé de départ cela veut
dire qu'on donne une retraite plus
longue un durée une durée de retraite
plus élevée voyez-vous et on voit bien
que
on peut pas avoir comme argument de
donner une durée de retraite plus élevée
aux femmes par rapport aux hommes parce
que il n'y a pas de différence
dans l'espérance de vie c'est la même et
en conséquence nous rentrons dans une un
droit qui sur le plan européen est un
droit discriminatif des hommes par
rapport aux femmes donc nous n'avons pas
retenu ce type de dispositif voilà ce
qui nous a animé et à faire cette
proposition d'une surcote anticipée et
là aussi on va à l'encontre des
dispositifs actuels du système de
retraite puisque la surcote ne peut
intervenir que comme vous avez votre
durée de cotisation dites à taux complet
172 trimestres à l'avenir que vous avez
atteint las vegal et que vous travaillez
au-delà de cette âge légal avant de
liquider votre retraite et la raison
pour laquelle nous proposons un
dispositif
qui n'existe pas encore avec une surcote
avant l'âge légal
en conséquence nous avons proposé cette
disposition qu'à partir du moment où
vous avez
un trimestre de majoration au moins
dans le calcul de votre pension vaut 172
trimestres prises en compte dès
l'instant où vous avez MD une
pardon j'allais dire le sigle que je ne
veux pas dire une majoration de
trimestres qu'elle soit liée à la
maternité ou à l'éducation dès l'instant
où vous avez atteint votre taux plein et
on a mis l'âge de 63 ans je vais vous
dire pourquoi dès l'instant vous avez
atteint votre taux plein à 63 que cette
que cette réforme propose à ces mères de
famille puisque globalement ce sont plus
des mers de famille mais ça peut être
également des hommes puisque il y a elle
s'est répartition des majorations au
titre de l'éducation entre les hommes et
les femmes et dès l'instant que la loi
va vous demander de travailler jusque 64
ans nous pensons qu'il est tout à fait
légitime de prendre une disposition
particulière à savoir une meilleure
pension
qui prend en compte effectivement cet
effort supplémentaire
l'avantage également de cette
disposition par rapport à un agent
anticipé c'est que on réduit le niveau
de pension entre les hommes et les
femmes et j'entends surtout les bancs
que cette réduction doit être au cœur de
notre réflexion et qu'il faut faire en
sorte d'essayer de la réduire elle se
réduira n'est ruptuellement au fil du
temps compte tenu que les femmes sont de
plus en plus diplômées et qu'elles ont
des carrières relativement similaires
par rapport aux hommes et qui font que
on ira progressivement vers une
meilleure une meilleure égalité en ce
qui concerne des pensions nous avons
choisi
pour une présentation qui encadrée dans
le délai je fin
is un patient un trimestre de Major
ation que soit votre nombre d'enfants et
ainsi que vous travaillez dans la
fonction publique ou dans le privé et
puis d'autre part nous avons limité le
dispositif sur le plan financier à 4
trimestres soit 5% de cotes sur cotes
parce que sinon on tombe dans un
dispositif particulièrement onéreux et
nous savons que c'est très forme
est avant tout pour combler les déficits
et non pas forcément les creuser c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous vous
proposons cet amendement qui doit me
semble-t-il nous réunir
[Musique]